[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
comment remettre la sncf sur les rails
en 2020 sncf voyageurs a vu sa dette
exploser de plus de 80%
la sncf qui a souffert des répercussions
de la crise sanitaire doit rapidement
remédier à ces difficultés structurelles
préconise le rapport de la commission
des finances sur la situation et les
perspectives financières de la sncf
rendu public le 9 mars 2022
les sénateur hervé maurey stéphane
sautarel rapporteurs spéciaux pour les
crédits des transports terrestres de la
mission écologie développement et
mobilité durable font état de
l'inadéquation entre le modèle
économique de la sncf et les enjeux de
développement de la mobilité ferroviaire
en lien avec les engagements climatiques
de la france
les dernières réformes n'ont enrayé ni
la spirale de la dette ni la dégradation
financière de la sncf déplore les
auteurs du rapport
le modèle économique de la sncf n'est
plus viable
le mode de financement du gestionnaire
d'infrastructure sncf réseau dépend
largement des péages ferroviaires ce qui
le rend vulnérable aux chocs
conjoncturels
parallèlement la modernisation des
infrastructures n'est ni programmé ni
financer
l'entité sncf voyageurs n'est pas
suffisamment armé face à la concurrence
et pourrait subir une perte structurelle
de la clientèle d'affaires dépassant les
20%
enfin les sénateurs évalue à 550
millions d'euros annuels les surcoûts
liés à l'organisation du temps de
travail et au manque de polyvalence
alors que les perspectives financières
de la sncf sont donc incertaine les
régions sont de plus en plus mobilisés
pour financer le ferroviaire alerte les
sénateurs
la sncf doit engager une révolution de
gouvernance et de performance
il convient ainsi de réviser les
équilibres financiers entre l'état les
régions et la société dans la
perspective de diminuer les péages font
valoir les rapporteurs spéciaux
les sénateurs estiment indispensable que
la sncf optimise son organisation du
temps de travail et porte sa trajectoire
de baisse d'effectifs à au moins 2 % par
an d'ici 2026
il préconise également de porter au
moins à 3,8 milliards d'euros l'effort
de régénération annuelles d'ici 2030
afin d'assurer le renouvellement du
réseau
pour concrétiser l'ouverture à la
concurrence les rapporteurs spéciaux
propose également de sortir sncf réseau
du groupe sncf
il souhaite aussi que l'état dans le
cadre de sa politique d'aménagement du
territoire renforce son financement des
trains d'équilibré du territoire et des
petites lignes
pour découvrir les dix neuf
recommandations de la commission des
finances consultez la synthèse du
rapport
[Musique]